Es ist eine wahre invasion sechs jahren nach dem schweren seebeben an der nordküste japans mit einem
verheerenden tsunami in folge
passiert etwas extrem
ungewöhnliches an der pazifik küste nordamerikas in japan starben damals knapp 20.000 menschen im
Atomkraftwerk fukushima kam es zum super-gau und jetzt tausende teile wurden ins meer gespült und liegt seitdem
offensichtlich verschiedenen lebewesen als floß und die führen jetzt teilweise
7000 kilometer entfernt an der westküste der usa
zu einer invasion welche lebewesen genau in den vergangenen jahren auf plastik flößen den pazifik überquert haben und was das jetzt für
Konsequenzen hat zusammengefasst also wie ist die lage in nordamerika jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Die amerikanischen meeresbiologin und biologen haben nicht schlecht gestaunt als sie das zwölf meter lange doch untersucht haben das
2012 am strand von orion angespült wurde genau wie auf vielen anderen objekten haben sie darauf nämlich knapp
300 verschiedene spezies identifiziert und zwar alle aus japan
Gereist sind sie wohl auf den unzähligen objekten die durch den tsunami
2011 in den pazifischen ozean gespült worden sind kleine plastikteile genauso aber auch ganze schiffe oder teile von industrieanlagen
Muscheln seepocken aber auch größere tiere wie krebse und bürger
Fische waren ihre passagiere und sie haben die lange fahrt von japan bis an den strand in oregon tatsächlich überlebt das ist wirklich verblüffend
zb in wassergefüllten löchern der trümmerteile und das kassel
Viele der tiere haben die lange zeit auf ihren flöten nicht nur überlebt nein sie haben sich sogar vermehrt ein rekord haben gleich zwei
langzeit überlebende gemacht sowohl die miesmuschel mit tilos gallo
Provinzielles als auch die seepocken mega balance rosa
haben 7000 kilometer zurückgelegt in sechs jahren und das lebendig zitat
Also wäre das erste mal arten aus japan in euren fanden waren wir geschockt
Wir hätten nie gedacht dass diese organismen auf dem offenen ozean?
So lange überleben können das sagt einer der beteiligten meeres ökologen john chapman von der oregon state university
Die meisten lebewesen kann wohl zwischen 2012 und 2014 an der amerikanischen küste an aber auch noch in diesem jahr ist das
forschungsteam fündig geworden und zwar auf trümmern die bereits
Im jahr der großen tsunami katastrophe 2011 ins meer gespült worden waren und seitdem
also
unterwegs sein die großteile der lebewesen nutzten die plastikteile als hilfsmittel für ihre überfahrt und das ist tatsächlich eine wirkliche neue
erkenntnis denn dass organismen auf holzstücken oder anderen natürlichen materialien durch das meer schwimmen das war bereits
Bekannt, so erklärt man sich dass viele inseln durch arten vom festland besiedelt worden sind in diesem
Fall ist die langlebigkeit, des plastiks, im wasser tatsächlich mal von vorteil zumindest für die passagiere
Denn anders als holz verrottet es nicht nach kurzer zeit und macht längere überfahrten überhaupt erst möglich
Dennoch ist die entdeckung, aus oregon wirklich überraschend denn bislang ging, man
Davon, aus dass solch ein floß mitten auf dem offenen meer einen mehr als
lebensfeindlichen ort darstellt vor allem für diejenigen
Organismen die sonst eher in küstennähe leben denn die uv strahlung ist auf dem offenen ozean viel stärker und zudem gibt es weniger nahrung unklar
Ist bislang noch ob sich diese organismen aus japan jetzt langfristig in den usa
Ob es sie sich gemütlich machen das hängt laut aussage. Des forschungsteams wohl davon ab ob genug individuen einer art die lange überfahrt
lebendig überstanden haben denn dann könnten sie sich in der neuen heimat verlieren die beteiligten mehreren um und ökonomen sind jedenfalls
Optimistisch zitat es würde mich aber sehr wundern wenn das keiner dieser organismen schaffen würde das sagt chapman was das dann genau für das
ökosystem an den amerikanischen küsten bedeutet kann man heute noch nicht abschätzen falls sich die neuankömmlinge
zu stark ausbreiten sollten könnte es passieren dass sie heimische arten verdrängen fest steht jedenfalls
auch dass sich in zukunft wohl immer mehr lebewesen auf diese art und weise
verbreiten werden denn in unseren ozean treibt wie wir wissen immer mehr plastikmüll also auch biologisch
Findet die globalisierung statt wenn er kein video zu diesem thema nach
Zu allen themen anderen themen verpassen wollte dann würden wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke sonst erfahrt ihr nämlich nie von
Den neuen videos hier bei pixum oder zumindest fast nehmen ja hier geht es weiter
mit riesiges bienensterben europa spannendes video wie immer hier und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran